you take a lead hey y'all goin everybody
girl how go that we talked about that
last time but I just think it's the most
genius thing you ever did was to shout
your own name during a music that is
genius I mean it's important not just
that you know my name is is to me I feel
like it's special you know and I feel
like you know everything I do I need to
scream my name as loud as possible
everything you do yeah everything I do
what everything that's mine I see you're
saying cuz if you're in a urinal going
let's think it's weird you know
and I always only do that if I know it's
a hit everything you know in certain
things and you hear me say another one
you know I mean in another smash hit
right right when you say another one you
mean this is another smash it had a
record you're not so sure up and you
just compare like DJ killin yeah I mean
you know I got I got different tones
when I say my name is you know each
record has a you know a different
feeling and sometimes you know what my
intros and stuff I get real how I say
passionate injure you know you know
passion pain success blessings you know
saying like it's just a vibe and you and
I are nodding but we don't know what
you're talking about
I've never been that excited about
anything in my life what I'm happy for
you thank you it's working for you
you